marlène schiappa est récompensé ben oui
elle reçoit le grand prix de l'humour
politique pour cette petite phrase on ne
va pas s'interdire des plans à trois
l'avait prononcée alors qu'elle défende
est son projet de loi visant à lutter
contre la polygamie je remercie pour ce
prix que je suis ravi de recevoir je
suis fier d'être ici avec vous en france
en france où une ministre peut rappeler
qu'on a le droit d'être mélange is
libertin abstinent bisexuels marié
fidèles divorcés trois fois marié avec
une personne du même sexe sans attaches
salchaud sexuelle ou même soliste voir
tout ça à la fois voir ça dépend des
jours je suis très heureux qu'il y ait
un prix de l'humour je suis un militant
de l'humour en politique je pense que
c'est très important de cultiver la
distance que notre monde aujourd'hui est
en train de devenir violent et que c'est
la disparition de l'humour qui annonce
des temps difficiles donc il faut qu'il
y ait beaucoup d'humour j'ai siégé
longtemps sénat côtés de pierre charon
je vous assure on a passé des moments
extraordinaires qu'est ce qui nous
empêche pas d'être sérieux même
quelquefois d'être sévères s'il était
élu la maintenant jeff tuche ils
feraient quoi ouf ça serait quoi sa
première mesure
tu crois pas que ça serait de faire un
break on va prendre
direz-vous d'une part tous en vacances
réfléchi voilà on fait une bonne
première mais si nous on se pose
merci sud est
[Musique]
22 20
alors à sortir d'incidents l'a
visiblement groupe de jeunes gens un peu
excités qui ont voulu passer devant la
caméra
pierre qui a donc
donné son analyse j'ai eu un rythme tu
t'attends à
mattia ouais y'a pas grand chose qui
arrive auxerre vandales vous avez vu les
quiches donc je suis allé voir à bas il
serait temps c'est le quatrième vous
avez vu non mais j'ai vu le 2 qui avait
vu les plus jeunes j'ai vu un bon pascal
g et wiba vous êtes déconnecté du pays
vous adressez vous voulez pas regarder
non non jeff tuche ne se lance pas dans
une nouvelle campagne présidentielle
mais assure la promotion de son dernier
film dans le nord pour l'occasion la
famille préférée des français était au
complet et en costume pour présenter les
tuche 4 à un public déjà conquis
[Musique]
j ai pas
heureusement
c'est très bien c'est la frite au
micro-ondes
bien ville sont très mauvaises ouais et
ben aussi mauvaise que celle qu'on a sur
le tournage c'est vrai c'est horrible je
crois que c'est les pires fluide que
j'ai changé ma vie bon alors on sait que
tu as mis ton
nom
[Musique]
les cannes à sucre à mon goût et
c'est dans
ce travail pour taper sans abîmer il
faut utiliser une planche entre le
marteau et la pièce de bois ce
charpentier n'a visiblement pas compris
la consigne et la vidéo fait le régal
des internautes l'histoire ne dit pas
s'il a finalement compris qu'il fallait
poser la planche sur l'objet vous en
voulez d'autres ce monsieur accroche son
sapin sur le toit de sa voiture sous le
regard médusé d'une femme l'homme a tout
simplement kifle et ses portières
passera-t-il par le coffre en tout cas
il a essayé laura c'est théo sont loin
de faire l'unanimité
ouais c'est ça qu'on dit comme ça
mais dynamique et les
humanités non ça ce sont des élus
d'habiter fait plus simple
[Musique]
la révélation de l'année c'est pour
l'écolo sandrine rousseau au sujet de sa
vie conjugale
n'importe qui peut être déconstruit moi
par exemple je me vis avec un homme
déconstruit et j'en suis hyper heureuse
par exemple est malheureusement toujours
pas compris moi c'est malheureusement
son of déconstruit ne l'a pas accompagné
hier soir pour récupérer son prix est
proposé à l'homme déconstruit devenir ce
soir mais je me suis dit que ce serait
la star de la soirée il n'a pas voulu il
reste discret
mais que vous arrive-t-il fabrice et là
à fond comme d'habitude je me lance dans
un tour hercule breton ça va devenir
j'espère un grand classique qu'est ce
que je vois bien que des je me promène
dans la rue avec un homme depuis cette
phrase il ya des gens qui me regardent
bizarre qui le regardent bizarrement si
l'on met des construit pas des construit
et déconstruit fin déconstruit que
j'avais l'impression qu'il y avait une
petite confusion entre la déconstruction
et la castration et je voudrais quand
même pas que cette confusion demeure
voyez par exemple les les porcelets sont
castrés à vif s'avère mais ils sont pas
du tout des construits après ça
jambes des moules est comme ça et
toulouse mais j'aimais ses petits sets
filant j'espère qu'à l'est pour moi
parce qu'elle est très belle
pose une question ton père qui travaille
dans un cirque parce que tu fais janvier
mon coeur
[Musique]
la thalie le hand tête à claques à
l'ancienne qui rime avec andouille nik
douil
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vrai ou faux un groupe d'américains a
gagné un procès contre red bull pour
publicité mensongère car red bull ne
donne pas réellement d elle
et ben moi je pense que c'est vrai c'est
que beaucoup d'américains toutes les
banques
toujours dans la nuance
petite claque à 400 millions
[Rires]
monsieur le dire à
avis à prendre et nous y sommes
je sais pas signé thomas thomas sotto de
télématin prévu d'aller au ski bientôt
thomas
je sais pas si thomas montant
il est pas là ben il est pas là ce matin
c'est moi parce que nous tend télématin
bonjour monsieur etienne pourtant on va
parler de du secret de longévité comment
vivre centenaire est en bonne santé ah
oui oui surtout jouit cigarette à la
main je ne sais pas du tout si je joue
ça doit être une catastrophe a dit c'est
vrai mais là bas tu vois les tue tous
les jours via l'ag joue bien un rôle à
l'aja moi je trouve que c'est plutôt pas
mal beau être si une autre femme paix
dans cette aventure je vais pas me gêner
d'aller voir une autre femme je suis
comme ça je n'ai pas de règles et ça
c'est dylan c'est dylan ils sont fous de
tout ils sont balech il n'a pas de
respect pour les autres
dylan bon allez c'est pas grave ça c'est
toujours pareil c'est le monde de la
téloche on en a rien à [__] c'est
magouille et compagnie